[Music]
little bunny learns bunny
learns the cow on the farm says moo moo
moo the goat on the farm says na na n
the duck on the farm says quack the
horse on the farm says neigh neigh neigh
Mo quack neigh
the Sheep on the farm
STS the pig on the farm STS oink oink
oink the hen on the farm says cl cl cl
the dog on the farm says woof woof woof
oink CL
woof the cat on the farm says meow meow
meow the turkey on the farm says gobble
gobble gobble the rooster on the farms
cocka doodle doo the donkey on the farm
says meow gobble cocka doodle dooo heaw
the goose on the farm says hog hog hog
the rabbit on the farm says St the owl
on the farm St hoot hoot hoot the Frog
on the farm sa ribbit ribbit ribbit honk
th hoot
Ribbit the be on the farm STS buzz buzz
buzz the mouse on the farm says squeak
squeak squeak the crow on the farm STS C
the Lamb on the farm says ba ba buz
squeak
the pigeon on the farm stays co co co
the bull on the farm stays snort snort
snort the calf on the farm says mo mo mo
the chick on the farm says Peep Peep
Peep C Mo
peep the donkey on the farm ssay Bray
Bray the llama on the farm SS h h h the
goose on the farm
SS the dove on the farm
stays Bray h
the cat on the farm says moo moo moo the
pony on the farm says neigh neigh neigh
the feasant on the farm says the quail
on the farm
says MO